hey everyone
welcome to this week's live session
today's topic
is python automation ideas but before we
begin
i'd like to thank our viewers for tuning
in and actively participating in these
sessions
let us wait for a while for more people
to tune in
also we have a dedicated team here to
answer
all your queries so if you have any
questions
let us know in the chat section we will
get back to you
all right i see a few more people have
joined so
this session will be about today's topic
which is python automation ideas
so let us begin we will go through
10 most popular python automation ideas
so brace yourself while we discuss every
one of them
first we will go through how and where
python fits in machine learning
prediction models and algorithms
then we look into web scraping another
popular
application for python automation python
is also used for tracking
stock market and cryptocurrency prices
after that
we will discuss chatbots increasingly
popular customer service experience
file management automation is common in
workplaces
again mostly powered by python
data mining also employs python for
structuring data
another good automation idea is to
automate sending reminders
emails and text messages excel
spreadsheets can also be read and
modified using python
python is also used to automate filling
up of online forms
in the end we will go through the
concept of internet of things and how
python is used in that field
so without further ado let's get started
first up machine learning machine
learning is huge
its uses spread across almost every
technological field
python is commonly used for implementing
machine learning models and algorithms
here are some most popular python
libraries that are used for solving
machine learning problems
first numpy numpy adds support for large
multi-dimensional arrays and mattresses
along with a large collection of
mathematical functions to operate on
these arrays
next we have pandas pandas offer data
structures and
operations for manipulating numerical
tables and time series
after that we have scikit learn
scikit-learn is a machine learning
library for python programming language
it features various classifications
regressions and clustering algorithms
including support vector machines
and other algorithms followed by that we
have tensorflow
tensorflow is also a library for machine
learning
it can be used across a range of tasks
but has a particular focus on training
and
interference of deep neural networks
some of the applications where python
automation is extensively employed
are industries industries have been
using machines for a long time now
but with the introduction of smart
machines python has come to use
in the industrial machines followed by
industries
we have hospitals hospitals use advanced
medical equipment
for monitoring various body conditions
the newer machines can suggest actions
based on specific conditions and for
that
python programming is required next
we have drones drones have become
popular recently
and they are mostly powered by ai which
in turn is powered by
python now
we will move into web scraping
web scraping is a technique used to
extract large amounts of data from
websites
and python is the go to language for web
scraping
beautiful soup is a python library that
is popularly used for
passing html and xml documents
it creates parse trees that are helpful
for extracting
the data very easily it will help for
selenium and pandas libraries to be
installed alongside beautiful soup
so that the data can be structured
properly and becomes ready for further
use
the extracted data from website is
usually stored in a local file
in the computer or in a database in the
form of tables
moving ahead we have the share market or
cryptocurrency tracker
python is used for tracking stock market
and cryptocurrency prices
let's look into it the prices of the
share market and cryptocurrencies go
up and down every instant so python is
used to track and protect the market for
profitable investment
even though the markets are highly
unstable python automation can provide a
trend
for a better purchase or sell
long short term memory is an artificial
recurrent neural network architecture
popularly used for applications like
stock market predictions
ls tm models are powerful especially for
retaining
long term memory and therefore can
provide trends using large amounts of
data
a well-informed investment can go a long
way and that's when automated stock
price trackers come in
which of course is powered by python
followed by share market and
cryptocurrency trackers we have the chat
bots
chat bots are in high demand and that's
why it is an amazing area for
implementing python automation
techniques
so let's dive into it chatbots are
becoming
increasingly common especially in
business and e-commerce fields
aiming to provide superior customer
service experience to buyers
chat bots are usually developed using
natural processing language libraries
like nltk
spacey etc these libraries can take in
hundreds of thousands of sentences and
then create a new sentence
as a response to a question chatbots are
automated customer assistance service
powered by
python they used to be only text based
but now more and more chat bots offer
voice support
with the advancements of nltk and these
libraries are completely based on python
so followed by chat bots we have file
management
python also offers automated file
management features
so let's have a look at it python is
used for automated file management
creating deleting renaming and other
file operations
a handful of python scripts can perform
full-blown file management operations
automatically or at a scheduled time
python scripts are used to perform file
management operations either on the same
file system or
remotely they are especially useful when
files have to be modified over the
network using some api technologies
so followed by file management we have
data mining
data mining is a process of turning raw
data into useful information using
methods involving
data science and statistics
python libraries like numpy and pandas
are useful
for making sense of raw extracted data
from any source including local file
or a website on the internet machine
learning models
like regression and classification are
further applied to
the structured data and bring out some
results
big companies often use data mining to
turn raw data
into meaningful information and gain
insights
so followed by data mining we have send
reminder emails and
text messages python is
often used in workplaces to automate and
schedule
sending or receiving of emails and text
messages
python packages like email smtplip
are used for sending emails using just
pyson
you can turn a time consuming task into
an automated or a scheduled task
emails and text are usually automated or
scheduled among
other tasks within a team to focus on
other development tasks
this increases productivity and
encourages better time management in a
team
so followed by sending automated emails
and text messages
we will advance into update excel sheets
automatically
python provides a module that allows
your python programs
to read and modify excel sheets
not just excel sheets but other formats
like
open office sheets or library office
sheets or basically
any spreadsheet excel is a popular
spreadsheet application by microsoft
but there are a lot of alternatives in
case you don't want to pay for it
open pi excel is a module based on
python
that you can install for working with
excel spreadsheets
and automating tasks using python excel
sheets
can be daunting especially when there is
a lot of data in spreadsheets
helps automate filtering of data based
and specified factors depending on the
data type
python provides crud that is create
update and delete along with other
features on excel spreadsheets
so followed by excel spreadsheets we
have fill
online forms python also offers
automated form fill features so let's
have a look at it
python is used to fill up online forms
automatically
any suitable python script can be used
to extract data from a file
and fill in equivalent online form
you can automate filling up of online
forms like google forms or
other sign up and login forms using
vanilla python scripts
forms can be submitted without any user
interface
you just need to provide data equivalent
to what is required to fill up
a particular form on the internet for
example
if a particular google form has fields
for name
age and gender python script should be
written exactly in the order
to fill up those fields followed by fill
online forms
we have internet of things so
lastly let's discuss where python fits
in the internet of things
internet of things is basically the
network of physical things that are
embedded with some software
sensors and other technologies that help
them get connected to other devices
on a network
python provides various modules for
developing services
and applications for many iot devices
like
arduino raspberry pi etc
packages like mraa sockets
mysql database and others are popularly
used for iot applications
python is used as a primary language for
iot
because of its compact syntax and fast
runtime speed
iot applications spread across various
fields like
smart appliances wearables etc
the ultimate concept of being an
interconnected world
more than ever so we have now covered
the most popular python automation ideas
there are many other users of python as
well but these are the most trending
according to the current scenario
you may use up these ideas for your
personal work as well as college or
office projects
and with that we have reached the end of
this video
hope you liked it think we missed
anything important
let us know in the live chat or in the
comment section below
if you are watching this later thank you
for watching this video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
you